Let's think about
calculating torque.
I have a force, F, being
applied to an object.
And that object is
pivoted at a point,
Q. I'll define R as the vector
from the pivot point, Q,
to the point of the
application of the force.
Torque is defined as the
cross product, R cross F,
which we can also
write as R times F
times the sine of theta.
But what does that mean?
I'll introduce two different
intuitive ways of understanding
this mathematical expression.
First, we can think about this
as the magnitude of F times
the quantity, R sine theta.
If we look at the
direction of the force,
then it is easy to
see there R sine theta
is just the part of R that is
perpendicular to the force.
So here the torque is
equal to the magnitude
of the force,
times the magnitude
of this perpendicular
part of the vector R.
This perpendicular portion
of the distance vector R
is often referred to
as the moment arm.
We can instead group
F with sine theta.
So this means that we're
thinking of the cross-product
as the distance R
multiplied by F sine theta.
The component of
the force F, that's
perpendicular to the
position vector R.
Here I'm calculating
torque as the distance
between the pivot point, and
where the force is applied,
times the perpendicular
part of the force.
Be very careful about
the sine theta term.
In many cases the angle theta
that is given in the problem
is not the angle that is
used in the expression.
In this example, F
times the sine of theta,
will actually give the parallel
component of the force.
Therefore it is much
better to remember
to take the perpendicular
component, rather than just
memorizing sine of theta.